there's this program on MSNBC called
Morning Joe you may have heard of it the
hosts are Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski they were spotted at Donald
Trump's mar-a-lago Resort in Florida a
few days ago and this is raising new
questions about what we might consider
to be objective journalism in the era of
Donald Trump let me give you the back
story back in February nearly a year ago
amazingly that's been nearly a year
since this there was leaked audio from
the set of the Morning Joe program and
we we heard Donald Trump talking to mica
and Joe during the break and it seemed
like they were really buddy-buddy and
and framing up a softball interview for
Trump and that this was not real
journalism that was going on later
though Donald Trump at one point
threatened to quote tell the real story
about the Morning Joe clowns as he
described them so we weren't really sure
what exactly is the working relationship
here now they've been spotted at Donald
Trump's party at mar-a-lago despite the
fact that Trump has been trashing most
corporate media even saying that he
would change laws to make it easier to
sue corporate media but they seem to be
part of the inner circle which maybe is
not part of Donald Trump's media wrath
it's fascinating in any case what
suggests a guilty mind more than a
Twitter meltdown with tweet after tweet
explaining way more than what seems to
be even remotely necessary the this is a
series of tweets that Joe Scarborough
sent after Twitter started saying hey
what the hell are you doing here are you
it are you Trump's friend are you
reporting what's going on so Joe
Scarborough starting I'll read some of
these tweets in succession around 7:00
p.m. I had a preset meeting with the
president-elect of the United States
before his party trying to set up an
interview much like reporters at CBS in
New York Times do going on to say the
event was black tie both mica and I were
in casual clothes did not attend the
party and left before any quote partying
began Joe Scarborough continuing noting
that Mika and I did in this setting in
setting up this meeting was any
different than what all good reporters
and news hosts try to do daily and
ending with anyone suggesting otherwise
is a hypocrite
who ignores what great journalists from
Ben Bradley - Tom Brokaw have done for
years of course uh joe scarborough
was reportedly at mar-a-lago last year
during christmas for an entire week but
and paid for by donald trump but this
isn't really about joe and mica I mean
do you care about this specific thing
Pat about Joe and mica being at this
party or for you are the concerns more
broadly about how Trump will relate to
media right I don't think there's any
suggestion - to see that the
conversation was untoward in any way but
it's really just a symbol of the
corporate media and people like Donald
Trump just being buddy-buddy and kinda
hanging out that's what's more offensive
I think I feel that the tier system of
media that is quickly developing under
Donald Trump is the bigger concern here
yet I guess Joe and mica are probably
buddy-buddy with Trump that's that's
what it seems like at the top of this
tiered media system under Trump are his
corporate media friends who get invited
to parties it appears as though Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski are part
of that tier next are the corporate
media enemies that Trump brought up to
Trump Tower and scolded and accused of
being liars and generally bad people
Jeff Zucker from CNN for example
executive at CNN was there and Trump
just just reaming people out there and
then the third tier is going to be once
we get to president Trump officially
there's going to be a third tier and
those are going to be the the
journalists that fall victim to Trump
trying to change libel laws to make it
easier to sue people in media that's
going to be the third tier the
lowest-ranked and that's that's really
interesting Pat because you're going to
see this staggered uh up so I ranking
it's almost like a caste system I don't
know what to call it
where if you're in with Trump you get
invited to the parties you're a great
person you're a great journalist you're
doing great work on the other side of
that if Trump decides that you're one of
the bad media people he might change the
law to make it easier to sue you it's
all about gaining access
and if you notice in the last couple
months of the election cycle Donald
Trump almost exclusively won on Fox News
because they were treating him favorably
the more uh I guess if we're trying to
find some silver lining here and it's
it's getting pretty damn tough the good
thing is that Donald Trump has more
influence over corporate media because
they depend on big business decisions to
stay afloat right we're mostly funded by
viewers and unless Trump shuts down
net neutrality totally which he would
love to do but I'm hoping he won't
actually be able to will be able to
continue to grow in the same way that
we've been growing because people will
go to david pakman.com slash membership
and sign up or they'll donate at david
pakman.com slash donate uh in a way we
are less at risk because the big
corporations that Trump might meet with
and say hey you know what they're not
being good to me over at CNN don't renew
your ad deal with them
fortune 500 company uh we're not really
going to be affected by that so if you
want to use the coupon code I voted
seventeen a david pakman.com slash
membership do it if you want to go to
david pakman.com slash donate donate a
few bucks to our campaign do it because
we're going to need independent media
that's been made abundantly clear by the
election of donald trump thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the david packard show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated